uh congratulations uh first of all
um the polls were suggesting throughout
the contest that you of the three
candidates were the most incompetent
weak and untrustworthy how are you going
to turn that around and not fail on the
S P's election winning machine that it
has been over the course of the last few
years well I'm delighted to be part of
that election winning machine and being
part of government for 10 and a half
years but on top of that of course I'm
delighted that when I've stood for
election I've been elected and
re-elected with a big majority from the
people of Glasgow Pollock who I'd like
to thank and putting their trust in me
uh over the years but what I'll make
sure I do is I govern and govern what in
the interest of the people of Scotland
but also we win the trust of the people
of Scotland when we govern uh and we
align with their priorities their
priorities have to be our priorities and
of course they will look to us for
delivery and I will do my best to
deliver what is their priorities and at
the moment I don't have to tell anybody
in this room that people are suffering
from a cost of living crisis that'll be
my first intermediate priority to try to
help them in that regard so I've got
every confidence not just in my own
ability but frankly the ability of the
exceptional sap team that exists not
just in the Scottish Parliament as good
and exceptional as my MSP colleagues are
but right across the parliaments and
local government and our active
activists based through